I need to deconstruct part of the studio
in order for me to get this guillotine
build done today I really didn't think
about this it's day three baby welcome
back welcome to day three of the
guillotine bill also video number two in
the three-part series where I build a
real functioning guillotine
still funny to me in this video we're
gonna finish building the entire
structure so everything except for the
blade and then the blade video will be
the next video after this everything's
gonna be done and all we have to do is
measure out the blade and have it
machined
[Music]
now the reason why I'm working in here
today is because Steve's with the
inspector and they're checking out the
whole building and we don't want any
cause any trouble by trying to construct
a guillotine in the hallway Steve gets a
little stressed out and the inspector
comes by and for good reason these guys
have just been the worst to him he's
done everything and more then they've
asked when it's a tactile exit stare
down and there's one over there by that
stairs off the loading dock and there
has to be one piss just in case that is
not big enough and I perfect in the one
above it yeah well I painted that myself
and if you'll notice it's extra big
that's six times the normal size of an
exercise I wouldn't know it though it's
very 16 pixels
that's it though that's even that's four
times look at that that's a proper one
normal life is like a Museum of exits
you know what's gonna happen
they'll have so much text to read they
may not get out of in time yeah well the
problem is is that he they once they're
done they then pass it on to the next
Department and then the next Department
has its own rules and regulations that
are like either repetitive or in
contradiction to the rules and
regulations of the department before it
I have no choice no I swear to God I do
you have no choice that's like five
inspectors man it's normal this is
building and safety and this wasn't even
this was last minute he kind of wandered
down here and said hey I think you need
some tactile lights and science and I
said before no oh okay
I just went okay because if you don't
want to go no yeah obviously the city
doesn't care they're just like yeah well
I leave it up to her people yeah I did
my job and every time I say something
gives me into trouble well I'm just
dealing with the bureaucracy I figured
did she keep pavers
I made music like that but I did it back
in 71 72 and I was inspired by Black
Sabbath
ever since boy what's that guy's name
see I'm not so many brain cells are gone
from so much LSD Ozzy Osbourne that's 50
you know when you draw the pass in 379
times in your life at least I remember
how many times you forget I mean my hard
drive I'm an old guy and my hard drive
is starting to get flaws
not having a bandsaw sucks I mean they
didn't have bad saws and 17th century
that's right
no they didn't but it's aa mouth
[Music]
[Music]
we pass okay and I just gotta raise the
science up those signs that tell
everybody to leave I gotta come back and
raise them up but Jake you can open up
the right you can open up the door now
the senior building inspector just
passed the work oh my god sadly that has
been a six-month nightmare yeah Jesus
$29,000 later Oh in terms of material
costs labor everything this soothing
music guy not about me
I'm gonna attempt to cut a one-inch
groove down each of these 12 foot long
four by fours and I don't have a bandsaw
or any of the other proper tools to do
this so I'm gonna attempt to do it with
the tools that I have before I work on
the other one I'm gonna see if I can
actually chip out some of the wood here
the dull last chisels on am I really
gonna chisel this out this whole thing I
didn't think this through yeah that is
how I want the whole thing to be yeah I
need something to shove under here so
that I can this is worst way to do this
how else would you do this though that's
what I don't get I can run the jigsaw
okay this is not the right way to do
this Nick that's a lot of jigging dude
what if I just drilled
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well you know I just asked for the
chunga's son
dude my tribe
[Music]
that sucked
but it works pick it up in the morning
on Monday yeah yeah we'll pick it up and
do this funny
salmon swim down nice super 73 bro let
me know what's going on around here
anymore so
[Music]
down
down hey yeah what's up man hey uh so
the books come along great as you can
see there's a lot of typos in here I am
right in the middle of murderer night
it's a murder mystery where I've been
accused of murder
I got cornered in the mansion so real
that I have to do a lot of proofreading
because if we want to release a book we
can't have any errors in it think we're
still set for our March release date
publishing this through Amazon directly
very very convenient way to publish and
write books but it's also very
convenient way to get them so a lot of
typos because we had to manually
transcribe these games from their
original layouts yeah the original books
what we have them around here but um
really low quality printing it's some of
it's hard to read I saw some comment
saying how can you take this authors
work and sell it we lawfully own the
rights to the book once again not a hoax
so the books coming out soon and I've
got half the book left to proofread wish
me luck
[Music]
yeah I played space and adventure last
night that was fun something crazy
happened this past week we launched a
sweatshirt and we sold out in the first
few hours of launching it which is crazy
we weren't expecting that at all so all
of you that bought it have now
accidentally created a limited edition
merch sale that's right up until this
Thursday we're going to be taking pre
sales for the sweatshirt at which point
we will go out and we'll make more of
them based on the number of sales that
we get we are only going to make as many
shirts as we get orders so if you want
one you have to put in an order by this
Thursday quality takes time because
these sweatshirts we actually went
through a multi-week process it took us
about six weeks just to get them made in
the first place you order a shirt in the
pre-sale expected around the first two
weeks of April that's when we'll get it
out to you but it's a really nice
sweatshirt head over to corridor digital
dot store to get one if you want one
this is your last chance they are great
you will not regret it I promise you all
of you that ordered one thank you so
much for supporting us it really helps
us out
for everyone who didn't order you'll
regret it now see Mike's words not mine
I said this is gonna be the very top
piece at the tippy top of the whole
machine and this is gonna be cut at a 45
degree angle here which is then gonna
have the five four is connected to it
like this basically this is the last no
4x4 that I have well usually I like to
get like an extra eight feet just in
case so I guess I actually measured a
little short so I thought I had more
than I needed this is just the best two
five seven it's important at a late
stage of construction to do things slow
and do things one at a time I've made
the mistake in the past of trying to
think oh I'm gonna improve my efficiency
by cutting all this stuff at the same
time when I'm in a late stage build once
I'm like at 90% or over I'll just start
cake
things one was one step in our hive
because if you screw up it takes way
longer time to turn today let me tell
you about a time tip son she know about
a time here
I'm like a time traveler me
[Music]
now stop it justice Wu's [ __ ] but but
you just told me the time tip huh I
measured twice two hundred three times
on the top looks nice right 39 inch 4x4
this thing's not going up today no
guillotine today goes so I'm really mad
I'm really disappointed
wait look don't go losing your head this
the head just to the guillotine isn't
finished yet man every time I try to
make a joke the delivery is just so
clunky that's it all right
I can't like I'm not gonna go to Home
Depot right now I'm just gonna finish
this scene I can't believe it after all
that delivery losing your head Jake over
us via T nothing done I mean I could
take a part of rail sure Sam and Nico I
need to just quick deconstruct a quick
part of the studio then I'll replace on
Friday so
clickbait how much time is setting you
back there has to be 25 inches from here
to here
dear Dobie we as that you make this cut
true and strong
oh yeah you know what's nice about the
sunshine and everyday time is that no
matter how bad your date is Sun gonna
[Music]
[Music]
help me with this end all right you all
remember when the Marines raised the
American flag on Iwo Jima that's a great
day in American history and today marks
a great day in youtube history for
corridor digital
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a bad use of time well after
five days of building we finally have
the structure complete I'm super excited
about this it's been a dream getting
here and now we need to make some small
adjustments to get ready for the blade
we'll see how that goes so in the next
video we're gonna be building the blade
installing the winch and seeing if we
can install the blade itself and a paint
job and a paint job I'm hopeful chopping
[ __ ] hopefully but I I think we still
have a little bit more together than we
think